so in this deep dive free class I'm
going to be breaking down a lot of
things I've never revealed anywhere else
in regards to online courses and
specifically I'm going to be talking
about how this is one of the best
business models specifically for YouTube
content creators and social media
creators of course it applies to any
kind of entrepreneur if you want to
start a side business but specifically
if you teach something or your YouTube
Creator you're going to be going to
definitely want to watch until the end
of this class I'm also going to be
talking about how you could tap into a
2.3 billion dollar per day industry and
get a piece of that the biggest mistakes
that I've made doing this so you can
avoid the stress the headaches the lost
money and ultimately go further faster
and that's one of our missions and goals
here at think media and then ultimately
three Secrets I've learned after
generating millions of dollars in online
course sales so buckle your seatbelt and
new data just came about that the
e-learning market is projected to hit
400 no
848 billion dollars
in the US by 2030. that's gnarly so over
the next few years it's projected to be
about 20 percent growth per year
this industry where people are doing
online learning digital learning online
courses is absolutely exploding if you
do the math on that that'll be about 2.3
billion dollars generated every day the
question is how can you get a piece of
that and a lot of people wonder how do
people make six figures seven figures
eight figures per year through an online
business how do content creators build
big incomes not just dependent on ad
revenue or brand deals and how do they
actually create businesses that are
sustainable so you're not trying to just
fulfill for a brand sponsorship and
you're frustrated working with them or
trying to you know get more views and
cpms and RPMs are up or down what is a
better way what is the sustainable
business model really it's not views
it's not brand deals it's not affiliate
marketing
smart content creators are creating and
selling their own products their own pro
programs and their own Services now all
that other stuff is fine and if you're
here live smash like my name is Sean
Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel and
I'm super passionate about helping
people figure out how to get views on
YouTube and get monetized and start
monetizing with affiliate marketing but
the truth is smart content creators that
actually build sustainable business Siz
eventually create their own products
their own programs their own services in
fact Business Insider this article says
creators are making big money teaching
online courses here's how one made one
million dollars in sales this was a San
Francisco woman who was able to generate
this another article revealed that this
couple created a DIY RV course
their name are Deborah and Barry Benton
they've been living in their RV since
2018 and they created a course called
Fix It Yourself they run a Blog and a
social media company called the virtual
Campground and this course was hosted on
teachable it had eight lessons about how
to care for your own vehicle and they've
generated over 22 thousand dollars
according to the verified income from
Business Insider and so people are doing
this in all kinds of topics and
industries no matter what your Niche or
your topic is the question is man how
could you package what you know into an
online course that you sell and
throughout this class I'm going to be
breaking down a lot of tactics and
strategies but here's why specifically
this is powerful for YouTube creators
seventy percent of viewers use YouTube
to help them solve a problem and so that
means that people already come to
YouTube with a mindset of wanting to get
educated yes many people come for
entertainment but there's a whole
segment of people that come wanting to
get educated and I actually was at an
event called social media marketing
World speaking and I believe it was the
team from either teachable or thinkific
which are online course hosting
platforms and I was hanging out with the
team and they said our most successful
users of our hosting platform are
YouTube creators or they're business
owners that have YouTube channels why
because on YouTube you can get to know
people you develop know like and trust
and then
um over time they go I want to go deeper
or I don't want just to like wait for
the next video or weed through the
videos on YouTube I want all the steps
in all the right order in an online
course so YouTube creators specifically
are some of the most successful online
course creators and that is because
that's how the platform is positioned
and you know ultimately though I how did
I stumble on this and you know today we
have a course that I believe is it's
been remade four times
we've actually probably created about 20
different online courses but our
signature course video record Academy is
five years old six years old but
ultimately I discovered all of this the
hard way and the point of this class is
that you get to cheat and get the easy
way I remember back when I was
discovering this I've been on YouTube as
many of you may know since 2007 I
started a channel for my small Church an
hour north of Seattle Washington I
started video in 2003 and the big
mistake I was making is I was focused on
views I was focused on just getting
subscribers things that we all want but
my focus was wrong and this was me
walking my two chihuahuas in Irvine
California at an apartment complex
called Los Olivos that my wife and I
were living in at the time I was
actually a campus pastor and we um were
kind of struggling because I was doing
my side income Ministry doesn't pay
super well
and Irvine cost of living is horrendous
I'm in Vegas right now streaming Urban's
about Irvine California is about 70
percent higher cost of living than right
here so I'm trying to figure out
actually how to make money on the side
because just on my salary from the
church we were actually hemorrhaging
money every single month out of our
savings so I'm hustling and this was my
home office and our thousand square foot
apartment pretty big All Things
Considered for Irvine but uh let me know
what you think in terms of a thousand
square feet is that big or small and so
um here's my home office you know I'm
out here hustling and I'm posting
YouTube videos with my extra time I was
earning a hundred dollars per month on
YouTube ads roughly at the time which is
cool this goes back to like yeah let's
do this let's get some views that was 31
000 views though
that generated 107 dollars and two cents
this is back you could see uh from
December 1st 2014 to January 1st 2015.
and so pretty cool to start earning side
income online problem is as many of you
know
a hundred dollars per month is not gonna
help you really pay your rent in a
significant way I want to say our rent
was 2 350 I definitely remember we
should have picked a different apartment
complex because each dog cost like an
extra 150 a month or something so like
talk about expensive animals but worth
it because aren't dogs amazing and so
then I was doing affiliate marketing as
well and I was earning between 280 to
400 per month affiliate marketing and
you could see these are the Amazon
payments back in uh 06 2014 to 10 2014.
so this is 2014. all right so I'm I'm
posting think media videos I'm actually
a little bit distracted across multiple
channels and I'm bringing in 255 dollars
a month 374 dollars a month you know uh
a range of different income coming in
right around 280 to 400 bucks a month so
a great month
is about five hundred dollars and a
lower month counting ad Revenue right is
around maybe 250 or 300. really cool and
please subscribe and we've got whole
videos and and you know we're here to
help you
start your YouTube channel and get your
first a thousand subscribers and get
monetized the point of a class like this
is realizing that again this is a long
and painful Road and sometimes the road
is actually too long for most meaning to
ever reach that full-time point because
if you're chipping away at dollar
amounts like this it can be very hard to
actually create a sustainable business
plus those numbers can go up and down
and again that was not enough to even
come close to paying my rent in Irvine
California but really probably almost
anywhere depending on where you live
right and I know we have a global
community and and I know it's all
different but here's the here's the
point uh what shifted for me was I
started to get educated and I started to
um look for a better way in addition to
building my influence with social media
I had become fixated on like if I just
get more followers if I just get more
views if I just get more growth but I
was focused on the wrong things and I
actually discovered a podcast that
started to shift my thinking the podcast
at the time has gone through a big
evolution but here's like a screenshot
of the old graphic from it it's called
build your tribe and yes this was my
actual iPod and my actual iPhone I want
to say six and um you could see my cool
Sony headphones and I would go to the
Los Olivos gym then the apartment
complex and get on the treadmill and
work out a little bit and get educated
I'm sure that's a lot like you you
listen to podcasts when you're walking
the dog or working out or doing chores
so I discovered this podcast called
build your tribe hosted by chalene
Johnson and I started to learn about hey
you need to actually like build a real
business hey you need to actually create
your own product hey you actually need
to build an email list hey there's
actually a better way and if you focus
on social media you're focusing in on
like step 15 and there's like 14 steps
before that you don't even have set up
yet and so I'm like on the treadmill in
Los Olivos Irvine California being like
my gosh and I've been hustling on
YouTube for years
expressing my passion having fun
sometimes sometimes it's real grind
editing and shooting having fun
expressing my passion but also being
like man this is this is a grind and if
I calculate out the math this is going
to take a while to get the ad revenue
and the Affiliates you know to the next
level and so ultimately I started to
discover that I was doing it the hard
way I was focused on YouTube ads and
affiliate marketing I left thousands of
dollars on the table because of not
doing what we're talking about in this
class and I was exhausted from
overworking for the results that I was
ultimately getting so then I will never
forget
because I discovered a better way to
make significant income online that
doesn't require being YouTube famous
which is one of our biggest passions
here at think media
because if you get famous one day and
many of our students do
then awesome but what I am most proud
about our unknown success students who
are maybe not famous but they're wealthy
because they're making significant
income online without huge followings or
being recognized in the grocery store
and so I'll never forget when I launch
my first online course following what I
had learned through chalene Johnson's
podcast and eventually her learning
program called marketing impact Academy
I launched an online course version 1.0
and it was janky I mean done is better
than perfect and I got more to tell you
about that but I did six thousand four
hundred and ten dollars in one hour I
signed up for a platform called kajabi
there are many different platforms to
host a course
and this is in 2016 you could see here
on six I don't know months what is that
June 1st
um and in the one day you could see that
there's little green over the following
days more money came in but in one day
and really one hour
I generated six thousand four hundred
and ten dollars now
I don't know where you are at
financially but this was a mind
expanding moment for me right I've
waited tables at Red Robin for 10 years
I was a busser I was a host I was an
expo I was the bird wearing literally
yellow tights in a giant red bird
costume true story awkward the the throw
distance is that the right word between
the crotch and the shoulders was not
long enough so I had to Arch my body and
literally I'm surprised I was able to
have kids today because of how this bird
suit affected my anatomy But ultimately
listen
um I had worked for tips I had worked
for getting paid every two weeks this
was more money than I had ever gotten on
one paycheck I want to say that maybe
not more money than I ever made in a
month but definitely way more money than
I ever made in an hour and I knew how
hard I was working on terms of all the
YouTube videos and all the affiliate
marketing and so here's what ended up
following the the total month after
launching an online course was seventeen
thousand and sixty four dollars in one
month and I did a lot of things wrong I
was smart because I didn't try to
reinvent the wheel I followed a proven
system and I followed a proven mentor
and I followed somebody that had done it
before because that's always the
smartest way to do it but still it was
janky and and not great and and still
needed work to be done good enough to
honor my customers let me make that
point clear that like you want to put
something out that that in
entrepreneurship and startups they would
call the minimum viable product the MVP
the minimum viable product like good
enough to go to market but it's version
1.0 and you can refine it as you go
that's why our YouTube course today is
like version four 5.0 because we add to
it we rebuild it but it was some good
enough to get the result and communicate
the promise result of the course at the
time so I want to be clear like you're
not cutting corners but there was 152
lessons I did not know yet when I
launched this course and I'm still
shocked by like the results that It
ultimately got so here's the big idea
and then I got three secrets for you
and again if you're finding this
valuable and you'd like more on this I
would love to hear any questions you
have about online courses plus hit the
like button if you find trainings like
this that are valuable that are a little
bit deeper dive so one of the best ways
to earn a full-time living on YouTube is
to create an online course based on your
knowledge and experience
this is the big idea
and you can interplace full-time living
for one of the best ways to diversify
your income as a small business owner in
case the world gets shut down again like
it did during the pandemic is to create
an online course based on your knowledge
and experience one of the best ways to
earn extra income even if you have other
income streams is to create an online
course based on your knowledge and
experience one of the best ways to earn
to double your income if you're doing
great with ads and Affiliates and brand
deals is to create an online course
based on your knowledge and experience
experience secret number one
I can make more money in one day selling
an online course than I can in the
entire month of YouTube ads and
affiliate marketing based on my math I
was able to make more money in one day
than an entire
500 bucks a month and really not even
but 500 bucks a month divided by 6 000
is six months
it would take six months at 500 a month
to generate six thousand and I did that
in one day this is true I can make more
money in one day selling an online
course than I can in an entire month of
YouTube ads in affiliate marketing and
this is why the online case in education
industry is so crazy now I know you
probably have a thousand questions and
you have different objections you're
like Yeah but isn't it crowded or yeah
but why would anybody even buy an online
course and we're going to be addressing
some of these things when there's free
information out there but I want to
encourage you to First consider the math
the trajectory of the growth of the
e-learning industry
by 2030 tells us a couple things number
one it is growing by more specifically
about 17.5 percent every single year
compounding
how many dollars are flowing into
e-learning people learning from home
buying digital courses doing online
education
a lot of money it's a couple hundred
billion right now it's gonna be over 800
billion by 2030. so if you position
yourself and you learn these skills
and you put something out there this is
gonna be a 2.3 billion dollar per day
industry it seems to only continue to
multiply meaning these projections to be
clear these are projections
but every data point is showing us that
real dollars are being transacted over
the internet and put into the pockets
of YouTube creators and teachers and
rvers that package what they know into a
course
the question is I know there could be
all kinds of skepticism and I I have
empathy for that and there's like oh but
what about competition and all this
different stuff and it feels saturated
like when you think about how big the
total addressable Market is we're
talking marketing branding kind of
higher level business terms here it's
massive and then when you go all the way
down to that couple that did RVs and
Business Insider highlighted them on how
to fix your RV and and save money and
they generated twenty two thousand
dollars you start seeing Oh that's
practical
you could go Sean you're this is just
hype and you can say whatever you want
but like look at the math
that generating 22 000 from an online
course is practical and that's what the
math is telling us right with
848 billion being the projection
the this is a c a g r is the compound
annual growth rate again is almost 20
percent in this industry this is Kerry
he uh has a couple different brands he
has shirt school he also has digital dad
he has two different YouTube channels
and he figured out how to do like print
on demand t-shirts as well as like
Facebook ads and had started uh how to
scale an apparel business and he did
that then he turned it into an online
course and he's now generated multiple
millions of dollars for him and his
family he's been able to be debt free
bought their dream home able to give to
their church and more causes than they
ever imagined the vehicle for changing
Carrie's life was creating an online
course so what is an online course what
is a digital product just so we're on
the same page there's a couple different
ways you can approach this you could
create an online course like that is you
film it all the videos are there all the
materials are there and it's done and
it's ready to sell in some cases you may
not even really need to update it that
much because perhaps the information
doesn't change a lot
with the course that I created on
YouTube yes YouTube changes so we have
re-filmed it re-shot it a couple times
another way to do is like a membership
site where there's monthly content
coming out and that's kind of even a
cooler way in some ways because if
things are always changing you just are
always doing new things every month then
there's also digital products which is
the whole idea here is could you create
it once and then sell it forever and
digital products could be like templates
downloads Luts Omar El takori who's one
of our think media content creators uh
he did his photography presets when he
was really heavily into photography so
he's wedding photographer couple's
photographer and he had a whole workflow
and he would teach about that on his
Omar altakora YouTube channel
and he then used his own Lightroom
preset so we sold them for twenty
dollars and then he put out a video and
over the video actually blew up and by
blew up I mean it got like 168 000 views
which is a lot but like it's not
millions and he ended up generating over
the next three months enough money to
pay their mortgage for their house in
Las Vegas something like almost two
thousand dollars a month selling a
twenty dollar digital download based off
something he knew his expertise
something that was related to his life
the reason this is so powerful is
because there's pros and cons and here
they are it is a growing industry it's
low overhead it's high margin Simplicity
Freedom low risk and scalability now the
cons is the competition
so no doubt about it you don't want to
be Cavalier with learning the skills or
learning how to Market or learning how
to brand or learning how to stand out
learning how to get awareness for it and
get the right people finding you get the
right positioning of your course the
right naming of your course the learning
curve I do think that while you could
put easy and air quotes nothing that
comes with building an online business
is easy there is a learning curve of
learning
well how do I package my course how do I
structure it and that's why it'd be the
easy myth whereas it's
it's it's easy perhaps compared to your
grandfather and your grandmother my
grandmother and grandfather met in the
military in the Air Force I think it was
called the Army Air corps at the time my
grandmother was a mechanic uh for the
airplanes my grandfather was a pilot
and they uh eventually once they got out
of the military launched a dental
practice and had to like Word of Mouth
newspapers Billboards you know I don't
think they ever did a billboard actually
and they built up their dental practice
and and all that kind of stuff and so
when you when I think about the toil and
the grit of my grandparents compared to
the complaining of this like entitled
present world where it's like man it's
so hard I gotta like sit at my computer
and like record some videos and upload
it into a membership area and then I
have to figure out Facebook ads so
there's a level of like it is easy
you're not like in a field with a
pickaxe chipping rocks apart
but the easy myth is that this is a
whole new set of skills where this is
kind of like knowledge work versus
manual labor like they'll get it twisted
here in Las Vegas in summer if you're a
roofer that's some freaking hard work
110 degrees Sun beating down sweating
your eyes out like that's that's hard
this is hard too but also think about
the pros and so I I like to try to you
know always tell you the truth and tell
you like and shoot straight to say like
I get the tension oh you're just saying
like it could be like a get rich quick
it's not get rich quick it is learn the
skill set it's learn how to do it but
it's also honoring this is a growing
industry so you're positioning yourself
in growth low overhead you don't have to
lease a building like my grandparents
did you don't have to pay for crazy
amounts of advertising you can grow your
course organically just with the effort
of of creating social media content High
margins because it's digital and you
don't have a physical business my father
is an entrepreneur my stepdad Phil and
so he gets million dollar contracts but
sometimes the margins can be super tight
or even jobs could be not profitable
when millions of dollars are transacted
because a water line breaks a truck
breaks down a piece of equipment breaks
down so when you start thinking about a
digital product you could transact over
the Internet the margins are high the
Simplicity of the business model
once it's set up and once you build it
once the fact that you could continue to
sell it the freedom of the business
model that you can work from anywhere in
the world the risk that's one thing I
think that you didn't put yourself out
there leasing a building buying a coffee
machine buying all the point of sale
iPads you know setting up your sign
buying tables hiring a team only to
learn that 12 months later like it
didn't work out
nothing is without risk but the cool
thing about a business model like this
is that ultimately
like what's the worst that could happen
you don't have hundreds of thousands of
dollars of debt in in drilling equipment
or so you know what I mean like it is
the best business model and it's
scalable so you can continue to scale it
especially as your skills multiply you
know it kind of reminds me of McCain dog
training who help people have a
well-behaved four-legged family member
and I remember they became one of our
students uh years ago their channels I
think much bigger now this is like an
old school screenshot that I was able to
take of even the old subscribe button
all this different stuff what was wild
was getting to hear their story and
we've also gotten to meet up at vid
Summit or VidCon these different events
but I would never forget that during
this the pandemic they have a physical
dog training business in Canada and they
have employees they have overhead and
then Canada even more so strictly locked
down and shut down everything and the
U.S shuts down everything and the
world's going through this crazy time it
was a very disruptive time
those who built their online influence
and those who turn their knowledge and
their experience into an online course
didn't just Thrive doing good times they
were able to survive during bad times
and so their online course was able to
help them support their business when
they weren't allowed
because of government overreach to
do their business physically and so they
have their life skills course the McCain
dog method for training for uh your dogs
and this particular course is 397
dollars
you could do a promo there's a coupon
code that people could do and I'm sure
you've seen websites like skillshare
people are making courses about
photography or presentation or drawing
or social media or freelancing
guitars you've maybe seen a site like
you to me to be clear I do not recommend
uploading your course to places like
udemy or skillshare I mean it beats a
poke in the eye it beats a kick in the
pants but that's not what I would do
because I would want more control and
those are platforms that actually you're
on somebody else's platform you don't
really control your own brand plants in
Lucia has built upper channel to over 50
000 subscribers and is monetizing in
multiple ways that's what's also kind of
exciting about this because for the
YouTube Creator she's doing ads and
she's doing brand deals and she is doing
affiliate marketing but she also created
an online course and it's called lights
for houseplants 101 it is 12.99 but now
think about that the transaction fee is
something like three percent on there
and so at thirteen dollars I don't know
math it's gonna be 30 cents 50 cents so
she's able to pocket 11.50 or something
like that if she sells one online course
do you know how many views you have to
get to even make eleven dollars you know
how many affiliate sales you have to get
to make eleven dollars
so even at a low ticket course if you
she gets all the money basically and is
able to then say okay it's also most
people are going to be price insensitive
just like here her if you're obsessed
with plants you're like 13 bucks like
I'd love it to get your step-by-step you
know she talks about how to use a light
meter and keep your plants healthy this
is a real skill set too you know one of
our beloved team members here at think
media Melissa is a plant mom and uh at
Anderson Studios which is Kyle's house
his loft where we shoot our podcast in
Las Vegas
um he's got these plants around and he
doesn't have her skills so his plants
are always dying so sometimes you need a
plant mom to come into your life to help
you not murder your plants and so when
once you get into this kind of stuff
you're like yeah 13 bucks think about
what people are spending their money on
and and the myth and the mind blocker
you may have is like yeah well why would
someone pay for that
well you could say that I mean it's as
simple as saying people do
and you may not but thousands of people
are millions of people are and I would
argue smart people buy online courses
because they understand the speed of not
just searching for free information but
figuring out I want to learn how to
light house plants it's like smart
people buy books some people why would
you buy a book I could just like ask
chat GPT yeah okay good luck but
ultimately when you buy someone's book
that they've taken five years or ten
years or 20 years for 20 bucks and you
get all their knowledge and experience
and perspective smart people invest
money in knowledge
and so while it might seem outside of
the box to think why would somebody buy
a lights for houseplants course when you
can say it that's the problem I want to
solve I want it short I want it quick I
don't want any ads I don't want any
brand sponsorships in it I don't want to
have to skip ad here on YouTube I want
to just go right through a program that
will teach me the skill I'm trying to
learn
so just another example secret number
two we're talking about three secrets
that are all around this idea of the
smartest online entrepreneurs people
that are starting a side House on
YouTube creators are packaging what they
know into a course that they can sell
secret number two is I don't have to be
an expert to create a profitable online
course
well Sean what do you mean
like wouldn't I want to
of course you know make something great
and I need to put something out there
well yes absolutely
but one of the things that holds people
back is they think man why what I don't
know anything yet I'm not an expert or
anything I don't have a degree in
anything
but the good news is this you don't need
to be an expert
like somebody if you're waiting for
someone to walk into your house that for
some reason is wearing night armor and
they come in with a giant sword like
cloud from Final Fantasy VII they sit
you down and they go get on your knees
my child and then they Knight you and
they're like you are now an expert you
are allowed to create an online course
good luck and then they just disappear
in a puff of smoke and you're like what
just happened
I predict that that scenario is not
gonna happen in your life right I mean
you you probably agree with me
like if you're sitting around waiting to
become an expert when's that gonna
happen
and what you'd be shocked by is there's
millions of people making money with
online courses
who aren't experts but they're an expert
in the way they do it
they're not experts they're just
experienced like how do you become an
expert in fixing RVs you drive around in
an RV for a while you have a lot of
stuff break
and then you figure out how to fix it
and you've gone through a lot of pain a
lot of struggle a lot of hardship in
fact some of the greatest qualifications
for grading an online course is if
you've gone through struggle and pain
and you've made a lot of mistakes and
you've you've had to fix more things
than most people which means you're more
experienced and you've found ways to
overcome things you're an expert in the
way you do it you and you rv'd for a
couple thousand miles and you're like we
broke down here the hot water heaters
here and the alternator here we had to
figure this thing out here we couldn't
actually like pump out our poop here we
had to do it some other place and you
share what you know
you're an expert in the way that you do
it so tip number one under secret number
two is you just have to be one step
ahead
one step ahead
um this is Jeff Bethke he's got a Bible
study course about digging into the word
online Workshop 50 bucks about an eight
week eight part I should say online
video course with practical
thought-provoking that'll help you read
the Bible with more clarity excitement
and freshness
so I actually don't really know Jeff's
full background but I
I pretty sure that uh maybe maybe he
went to Bible School
uh maybe he's had some time in Minister
Ministry but I don't think he's a pH
he's not saying he's a pH you know what
I mean like he loves the Bible
has studied it has learned and studied
under others now he's teaching what he
what he knows in a 50 online course
right experienced and by the way the
reason I bring up this example is
because if anybody is familiar with
inside kind of the church world in the
Christian World which is a world I'm
very passionate about as a Christian
myself like there's a lot of different
perspectives that people have and for
those that would call ourselves like
Orthodox Christians we agree on
essential things like who Jesus is what
the gospel is but as far as like even
like
how to approach reading the Bible and
you know the original languages are now
brought into some different modern
Trends and some people get really
passionate about weird details and if
that causes division it's kind of toxic
but if it's like yeah like we agree on
these core Essentials of what
Christianity is but then there's also
like these other things and so
the key is that as you're building up
your YouTube channel your way of doing
it your brand your style people who
start to develop know like and trust
with you will want to do this course
your way
though by digging into the word with you
other people will be like I don't even
agree with Jeff well they're never gonna
buy the course and they're not going to
subscribe to the channel do you know how
many different somebody wants to go get
a they want a PhD person to do it Jeff's
crushing it he doesn't have a PhD
the only point I'm trying to make is you
don't have to be an expert
and here's the second big opportunity
and tip number two beginners are always
the largest market and one of the best
audiences to start with
meaning this
it's really good news that you don't
have to be an expert because
if you're one or two steps away from
being a beginner then the course you
should create should be for beginners
it would absolutely be a mistake and I
believe a lack of Integrity if you also
pretended to be Advanced or to pretended
to be further than you were so as soon
as as soon as you do real estate for 12
months
you could make
a low-cost affordable online course
on getting started in real estate
five things I wish I knew how to get
your real estate license because you got
your real estate license
how to do a couple deals because in your
first year you did a couple deals and
then you're like this course is for
people who are considering getting
started and are a beginner at real
estate
in Washington State
some specific market and someone goes I
just want somebody that maybe they
discovered you on social media
even very few people and they're like
man I like your Vibe I would I like the
way you communicate and and I would love
for you to just kind of hold my hand for
25 bucks for ninety seven dollars I
would love for you to hold my hand and
just get me started big opportunity
beginners are always the largest market
in any industry so it's one of the best
audiences to start with I found this
course on udemy chat GPT Mastery the
beginner to master course it's already
sold 95 94 students it's generated 1 425
which also proves the point
why would people pay for information
when there's so much free information
because they will
because some people understand the value
that when you pay you pay attention that
ultimately when you pay it a lot of
times leads to more transformation when
you want a result but also you want it
all organized you just want somebody to
explain it to you this is a two hour and
eight minute course why do I bring this
up there's no way this person could be
an expert why this chat CPT has been out
for four minutes
so you're like one or two steps ahead
that's as many steps as possible you
might be the leading expert because the
thing has been around for four seconds
and you're like and but if you stayed up
all night made some coffee got super
into it AI is super cool I learned some
things I made some mistakes if you've
clocked 40 hours doing it I want to talk
to you
because I could I could shorten my
learning curve
if I talk to you for 40 minutes about
what you learned in 40 hours the power
of online education the consolidation of
information helping people go faster and
people want to invest money when you can
help them do that so here's three
mistakes I made
that'll help you when you're making your
online course
the first biggest mistake I made was I
made it an advanced online course when
starting now I'm not contradicting my
advice here because when I say Advanced
I also mean how big the course was I was
I was not a beginner when I first came
for course came out in 2016. I have been
doing YouTube
for nine years at that point and I had
figured out how to rank videos and earn
money with affiliate marketing so I was
teaching something that was proven
repeatable that had worked for other
people I had coached a few people and so
but the problem
was I bit off the biggest thing I could
have ever been and I made when I you
could intersperse advanced for like
a
like a long course
don't make a month-long course when
you're just starting don't make a
year-long course you're like what I'm
what I'm gonna do Sean I love this video
that's why I hit the like button because
I'm grateful and what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna found a university an online
university for chat GPT
I mean do you do you but you may want to
just create the mini get started course
first is all I'm saying so that was a
mistake I actually my first online
course was insanely heavy and hard to
build
um which is the second mistake building
an extra large online course and also it
was I made a course and if you interview
a part of video record Academy it is a
good class course for beginners but it's
also pretty Advanced we just uh brought
on a new person to our team named Brooke
and she was like
this Academy is
she was like this thing is robust she's
like there are some stuff and I was like
oh yeah you know because I was also kind
of like overly concerned with wanting to
give as much value as possible which is
a good concern wanting to over deliver
which is a good concern but when you
really understand the person that you
want to serve like what are the building
blocks this is also why we have since
then gone backwards to create smaller
things to help people even prepare to be
a part of our Academy which is a much
larger and then the other one was just
waiting too long to start
I actually was I wish I had the exact
training you're listening to right now
because I I had too much negative
self-talk or myths or false beliefs
about oh I'm not ready yet you know who
would listen to me
like who even buys an online course will
this be a waste of my time all this
other stuff I really did wait too long
to start and it's all about starting
fast starting messy and here's the
secret here's how you start fast you
create a quick win or an introductory
course
simplify it down the ones I showed you
of like plants and Lucia
like that course is like 20 minutes it's
she really broke it into very quick and
educational bite-sized things and she's
like step one do this it also is a big
myth that I've learned that people want
long they don't want long they want the
answer
we're all so busy do you ultimately like
oh I want 100 hours of content I don't I
don't want long I want the solution I
want to just get me that quick win get
me that thing so what could you make
that's like seven bucks that's 27 bucks
that's you know a hundred dollars that
that gets a result that teaches people
the eight things they need to fix their
RVs so for example
um
the animation on this slide was a little
awkward so let me just show you all the
things
um so like the marketing impact of
Canada Academy this is my friend chalene
Johnson's course this is really year it
is like a university it's really not
even an online course it is a Learning
Resource
she's created assessments she's got
people that like help you she's got like
Tutors or like uh faculty and you pick
and choose things as you're building
your online business and it is
incredibly robust
so that's like years
I do not suggest starting with that
imagine like four years college degree
and the cool thing about the way it's
structured is it's not that it has to
take that long it's that you use it as
you go but you continue to to reference
it like an encyclopedia and it's very
effective at helping you just solve the
Now problem and get results as you're
building an online business so think
about it like college degree four years
video record Academy and this screenshot
was back when it's called 2.0 then we
removed that now it's called video
Foundation uh video record Academy
foundations and Masters and it's gone
through different Evolutions but this
was the version then this was months so
imagine you could have like a college
degree that could be a huge program you
could have a college class
and it takes you
three months four months to go through
it that's kind of like video record
Academy be like a college class then we
created a course called grow with video
that was really like one day it was like
eight hours
okay and then we created a course called
video product review profits which was
like
an hour one hour it was a mini course
that solved one clear problem it taught
one thing it really taught
affiliate marketing and video and like
like one hour crash course on it
so this is what I'm suggesting you start
with and a couple just different ways to
think about it don't create something
that would take years the university
don't even create the months not even
necessarily the one day what is the one
hour and let me pose some questions for
you again if there's the thing you teach
what would you teach somebody or the
thing you're experienced with or the
thing you wish you knew when you were
starting you're like man what I know
about parenting now what I wish I knew I
could would have starting what would you
tell about parenting
is a lifelong education right so it
technically is years but sitting down
and being like I'm gonna create you know
the ultimate
parenting University
and you probably haven't lived through
all this but it maybe you have you're
watching this your baby boomer and
you're like I could speak to all of it I
could speak to you know infants toddlers
adolescents teenagers empty nester
College schools every season
what would you teach in a year what
would you teach in a few months what
would you teach in a day what would you
teach in one hour
if you only had one hour to take your
thing package it up and help that person
then that's actually a really good place
to start and you'd be shocked about the
kind of money you could make and the
impact you can make with basically what
would be called like a baby course or a
mini course secret number two
this is repeating secret number two uh
is I don't have to be an expert to
create a profitable course
I told you this could be a master class
and we are halfway uh maybe further than
that but if you could get value let me
know your aha moment so far
um and
uh let me know I've got some starred
questions coming in as well so we we are
buckling our seat belts for today we've
got a lot to share and and uh let me
know your aha moment but we're on secret
number two of three secrets and um
secret number two is I do not have to be
an expert to create a profitable course
and I want to give you a second
framework
to show you the three different ways you
can get into the online course creation
uh game essentially without being an
expert this is really cool so these are
the three paths
to earning money with online courses
all right so here's the first one you
could be a knowledge broker a knowledge
broker
what's actually interesting about this
is
if you're familiar with affiliate
marketing
you talk about a camera you talk about
uh
makeup you talk about some exercise
equipment you talk about an exercise
bike you talk about a fishing pole you
talk about some sunglasses you talk
about some software and you share a link
in your description on a YouTube video
and someone clicks the link and you get
a cut
did you know that you can be an
affiliate
for online courses you could be just
like you're an affiliate for amazon.com
you could be an affiliate for online
courses well the reason this is
interesting is you can partner with an
expert
and you don't have to create your own
your own course you could be an
affiliate for somebody else's course and
this can be much more lucrative than
Amazon for example
and it may be that you already have some
level of expertise
um but you don't have the time or you
haven't got around to it yet or you
don't have the confidence so I've been
doing video production for a while and I
started think media where I'm talking
about cameras and video production and
all that kind of stuff
and as I tapped into this knowledge
broker kind of thing I discovered a
program called local video Academy and
it was all about how to actually start a
local agency in a local city and how to
like the emails scripts to reach out to
local businesses how to how to pitch
them how you'll help them and make video
advertisements for them how to do the
services even if you want to run ads for
those local businesses how to do it and
all this kind of stuff I had done some
of that since 2009 when I started
clearvision media
but I definitely didn't have any
templates or email follow-ups or any of
that stuff and when I thought about all
that I was a little overwhelmed
so I discovered their program so I was
like huh and I'd been following the
creators for a while and so I looked do
they have an affiliate program sure
enough they did and they were actually
paying 50 commissions on a course that
had two levels I think it was two
thousand dollars or there's a three
thousand dollar level and they helped
you more
um like onboard everything or they gave
you some more coaching or put you a part
of a group and again this would like
help you
sell video services to local businesses
so I was like wow this is pretty cool
because if you found somebody else that
has an online course this is the
strategy related to like the YouTube
channel you're building but you're like
man I don't know if I'm gonna if I have
time at this moment to sit down and
create that or the people who are
watching me would be interested in this
and people who are watching think media
either wanted to how could you make
money with your camera you could start
doing video marketing Services maybe
you're already a freelancer of some kind
but you were struggling and so if you
learn from somebody who had all the
templates and everything else so I made
one YouTube video about it I put a link
in my description and then I ended up
doing I think two sales and I want to
say
it was one of the higher end or one of
the lower end and I forget because it's
been now back in like 2014 or something
as I started going through build your
tribe in the marketing impact Academy
learning how to do all this and I ended
up making 1 500 this is when we were
living in Irvine
just as the knowledge broker right so
the key is that for some even sitting
down and making your own online course
first is probably not the first move or
depending on how much time you have if
you simply learn how to what some people
call as a joint venture partner or an
affiliate partner and So you you're an
affiliate for someone else's course the
other cool thing about this is you might
be you know level one or level two of
your knowledge
but you're like I would like to promote
another expert
see the power there so if you even if
you're slightly insecure not in a toxic
way and just you're like I don't quite
actually have the credibility yet I want
to get behind somebody else's thing that
I can support so this is one path that a
lot of people actually don't really
realize and don't think about how to
integrate but then there's another path
and that's the reporter so you could be
the knowledge broker you could be the
reporter
the reporter have you ever heard of the
book Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon
Hill you ever read it
so Napoleon Hill nearly a century ago
was just a journalist essentially and he
studied over 500 self-made millionaires
including Henry Ford and Andrew Carnegie
and Charles Schwab
um he he may or may not have interviewed
them like it's actually under a deep
scrutiny of of like it is it recorded
that he said he met Andrew conned he
probably never did separate conversation
the punchline is he studied them this is
what the reporter did
you study the attributes of other high
performers if you look at someone like
Tim Ferriss who's an incredible
entrepreneur investor in his own right
but like he talks about his podcast I
want to deconstruct
the lives and the businesses of high
performers
so what I love about the reporter model
is this is why if you have a an
interview show where you bring on
Experts and you synthesize the
information from other experts there are
many authors and course creators today
who have best-selling books and
best-selling online courses synthesizing
being a journalist being a reporter and
what's cool is you can actually do both
of these so imagine if you have a video
podcast you can be a knowledge broker
you could be a reporter and you don't
have to be an expert secret number two
you don't have to be an expert to create
a profitable online course think you
grow rich is nearly it's one of the um
best-selling books of all time
right and so
finally
you can eventually be the results expert
or maybe that's already you so which one
do you like best type which one would
you start with knowledge broker reporter
or expert
so then eventually you have the results
this is the key and notice that even the
foundation of the pyramid this can even
be a journey this was my journey as well
if you're not the expert you just start
brokering other people's knowledge but
what happens during that you start
learning and growing yourself you start
you interviewing others or studying
others which I'm sure you do success
leaves Clues so you study others with
success you then apply what you're
learning and eventually you get the
results and so it really becomes a
transformational experience where yes
Carrie who's doing the T-shirt school
has sold hundreds of thousands of
dollars and millions of dollars in print
on demand t-shirts and so now he teaches
other people how to do that the good
news about this though is anywhere on
your journey you can get started
personally I took online courses I read
books I interviewed experts I learned
skills I practiced I took action I got
results and eventually I became an
expert so not only are these three
different paths there also can be kind
of a compound effect and I would argue
that the best and most sustainable
creator businesses do all three like
there's no reason why you can't like we
continue to promote and let people know
about products and programs and books
and resources that have changed my life
changed our company's life I probably
it's probably not a video that goes by
that I don't recommend a book you know
what I mean or something like that
that's kind of not a knowledge broker
affiliate link I make 22 cents you know
what I mean if you click the link like
and so uh being a reporter like either
breaking down what other people did a
lot of YouTube creators do that as well
like you see videos of like Warren
Buffett's 22 top secrets you might not
be a world-class investor yet but you
can study them and even interview them
or Break It Down Like Napoleon Hill did
but then over time you eventually become
the results expert
and so which one do you like best I'm
curious and which one would you start
with most confidently
um and in just a second I've got secret
number three for you I've got a whole um
uh really powerful two more Frameworks
to share with you I bit off more than I
could chew I mean I think we'll be all
right but we're 52 minutes in and uh I
can't even imagine if you're still here
I really am grateful that you're here
and I would love to know your aha moment
how to vid says that's the best book
I've read so many times it is a really
good book I love the Black Edition oh I
gotta check out the Black Edition they
could Grow Rich Black Edition that
sounds cool uh is there gonna be a
replay yeah this video is on our think
media podcast channel so I definitely
recommend uh saving it you know share
this if you're getting value smash like
if you're getting value
um and yeah that's right Shannon reach
out to course to see if they have
affiliate programs great ideas uh
knowledge broker I love it Susan really
good A lot of people read the book I'm
glad you're getting value checking in
with y'all I see you creative thanks for
being here
um and thanks for all the love
so much value glad you're getting value
awesome awesome I'm coming to you for
Vegas too so you can shout me out
wherever you're watching from David I
appreciate your kindness so we've got
secret number three but I also I do want
to let you know if you're this far and
you're like okay this is pretty cool and
I would love to learn more about this
um and go deeper and is there even a way
I can learn all the steps of building an
online course and go a lot deeper than
that if you haven't heard yet
we are doing a special collaboration
with my mentor chalene Johnson
um it's at Mia bonus.com I'll tell you a
little bit more about it later but um
we've actually put together some four of
our best programs in conjunction with
her marketing impact Academy which is
the program that I learned how to do all
of this in so when I was trying to
figure out how to launch an online
course we've actually in full
transparency done over 10 million
dollars now over eight figures
um in our kajabi account
um and
it's quite a bit higher than that now
but whenever last time we checked and
the punch line is it didn't happen by
accident of course it came by hard work
skills learning all that stuff
um but as I got started I followed
somebody who wanted to do it step by
step so if you want to learn more about
that I'll tell you a little bit more
about that later but am I a bonus and
there's a link in the description down
below as well which is really everything
you need to know and by the way
ultimately the the program that chalene
has isn't about creating online courses
it is about that but she's got deep
online business Ecom opportunities
Shopify lots of different ways it's
bigger than that but that was how I used
it because I saw okay
um some of the stuff I'm sharing with
you here I was like man online courses
are the best business model
but I don't know how to Market I don't
know how to Brand I don't know how to
structure this stuff I don't know how to
package it all together I don't know how
to do any of that stuff so that's where
I learned it all uh Mia bonus.com if you
want to learn a little bit more about
that but secret number three I don't
need a large audience to have a highly
successful online course
so the truth is
you do need a large audience to make
money with affiliate marketing and
YouTube ads and everything else
yes brands are paying micro influencers
and Nano influencers but the math I
shared earlier in this video
reveals just kind of the correlation
between of course views and money and
that should really be a surprise to us
the amount you're paid by a brand or by
YouTube for running ads or by the amount
of clicks you can get on your affiliate
links is of course directly correlated
to the amount of money you make
the reason being too is it's essentially
cpms cpms are so low if you make
ten dollar cpms or five dollar cpms you
only get half that or less for every
1000 views that an ad actually runs on
whereas in the meantime imagine if you
get a thousand views on a video
but that video then talks about
something that is your own product your
own service or your own online course
something you own and something like
plants and Lucia where you make almost
11 50. you make eleven dollars and fifty
cents of the 12 offer plants in Lucia
makes more in a day if she sells 10 of
those in a day she makes 120 in a day
she only gets a couple thousand views in
a day she makes like a dollar fifty in
ad Revenue right so this is kind of a
well-known fact but I think it's
important to know that you do actually
need a bigger audience to make affiliate
marketing in YouTube the YouTube ad
scale
audiences can also be fickle or views
can also go up and down so one of the
powerful things of course is to launch
an online course and here's the
Instagram post there's the first graphic
of video ranking Academy back in
March 3rd 2016. this is a special week
on March 1st I launched my first online
course called video ranking Academy it's
always been a dream of mine to teach
others
um and help others spread messages that
matter with online video in this course
is a major step towards realizing that
dream and I'll never forget my first web
class I remember I did a web class
uh webinar to talk about the course and
I made 87 mistakes
let me tell you some of them it's kind
of funny and then I got to give you this
framework so
I go live I am sweating bullets I don't
know how to do a web class we're sitting
here in 2013
2023. so this is six years ago I had
done exactly zero web classes so if
you're also like man this all seems kind
of stressful I get it that's why it's
really nice to have like coaching
through it and stuff so I get on and I
have my slides ready spelling errors
everywhere so as you would maybe still
you may see some today uh thank God for
Victoria she proofreads my slides these
days okay
and I remember I'm going through a lot
of times they'll say if you're gonna
make an offer like it should be at the
45 Mark or the 50 minute Mark so this is
even going through like best practices
okay
so I'm at minute
hour and 25. not A lot's changed and I
am
way past that time but I'm super
stressed too I'm like okay I got more to
say I'm super late okay whatever I
finally get to the place where I'm like
hey so if you've enjoyed this if you
want more I've got like another thing
and I I remember we had like a URL I was
like video rankingacademy.com
I have since also learned I don't know
how to spell academy
oh and and I and use simpler URLs and
use like easier to spell words because
if you can't spell it maybe you can but
if you can't spell other people probably
can't either so here's what's funny
though is every single slide the URL was
spelled wrong
so I'm at the critical moment
that my financial future is resting on
and we get to the sale in the webinar
and the URL is spelled wrong okay well
maybe people could figure it out because
someone's like oh it's spelled wrong now
you shouldn't assume that it's actually
one of like the basic principles of
online marketing is removing friction
like making sure things work making sure
they're clear they're simple
so if as if that wasn't bad enough
all that that what that was was a URL I
purchased albeit spelled wrong
um the actual URL video ranking we don't
even use that today it's too long it's
whatever
videoreggingacademy.com Academy spelled
wrong and it's it's on like 30 slides as
I'm describing this
I bought it on GoDaddy you go to GoDaddy
and you can forward a URL and the reason
I do that is because if you've got
teachable or thinkific or whatever it is
you
have some kind of a page and your page
is usually like
courses.shawncandle.com forward slash
you know sale forward slash five two
seven eight five six five you know which
is very hard to communicate so it's much
easier to say video rankingacademy.com
assuming people can spell it and
assuming you don't spell it wrong but
here's what was wild so I bought the URL
forwarded the URL checked the little box
called forward with masking all that
meant is that instead of seeing
courses.shankano.com 725-25673
it just stays pretty it just is like
video record academy.com
turns out kajabi
doesn't allow forwarding with masking
therefore the URL
did not work no matter what URL you
typed in
so let's let's play back the tape
I am now trying to sell my online course
the the very Doorway to get through to
the sale is locked
there probably could be no greater
mistake if in in the effort of of
ultimately launching and promoting your
online course
and so luckily I mean it was like oh
hang on excuse me wait in the back and
we like you like grab the URL and like
try to put in the comments and I showed
you the results like luckily still some
sales came in and still some stuff
happened but here became the good news
you have to start before you're ready
you have to be willing to make mistakes
you have to start messy and and we say
start Messi a lot here's the definition
of start this was pretty messy I would
never forget
David Goldstein who is a character in my
story it's just like uh you know he's
been a influence in my life it's been
encouraging not in this case I remember
he was like texting me before it's kind
of been a business Mentor just a guy I
met at church he's like Sean you're
gonna crush it tonight I'm like okay I'm
gonna crush it he's like you know good
luck I was like all right and then you
know I'm doing my webinar and I remember
at 45 minutes he's like okay is the sale
coming up I like see my phone bring
stress 10 out of 10. like David why are
you text me I can't change anything now
bring like another one and I need to put
my phone on silent he's like dude get to
the sale like what are you doing you
know all this stuff and I'm like give me
a break relax and then we get to the
thing and he's like URL doesn't work URL
doesn't work and I'm like I know it
doesn't work I said my phone's going off
anyways maybe you can feel some of the
emotions I feel
the encouragement is you got to get
version 1.0 to the market
and then you get the next version of the
market then you try again
next time I didn't use forward with Max
masking I had a chance to go back and
correct my slides and then the URL was
spelled right over time I learned other
best practices and especially as I
continued to go through the education
because I was all I was kind of
sprinting on all of this I'm juggling
family and I'm juggling like we'd moved
back to Vegas and we're trying to get
things going and we have you know at the
time my wife was having some pretty
severe health challenges you might know
our story so we're juggling a lot of
different things and so I was like
building the plane as it was flying as
we do as content creators and
entrepreneurs but that's okay just keep
building that's okay just keep flying
you know and so ultimately uh I learned
a concept though and this is number
three I don't need a large audience to
have a highly successful online course
you only need a thousand true fans
what does that mean well you can look up
this article and I recommend you do but
it says this to be a successful Creator
you don't need Millions you don't need
millions of dollars or millions of
customers or millions of clients or
millions of fans to make a living as a
craftsperson a photographer a musician a
designer an author an animator an App
Maker an entrepreneur or inventor you
only need a thousand true fans a true
fan is defined as a fan that will buy
anything you produce these Die Hard fans
will drive 200 miles to see you sing
they'll buy a hardback and a paperback
and an audible version of your book they
will purchase your next figurine sight
and scene they will pay for the best of
DVD version of your free YouTube channel
right a thousand true fans so check out
the article but check this out as it
relates to online courses if you were to
create a 37 course
and you had a thousand true fans now
maybe you have to 2200 YouTube
subscribers but some of those people are
really into your stuff they buy your 37
course you'd earn thirty seven thousand
dollars and imagine if that if you had a
year to do it
so this is the average teacher salary in
the United States is right around thirty
seven thousand dollars
so now think about the world we're
living in where you could package what
you know into an online course you have
a year to do it
make videos make some tick tocks dance
around do whatever you want
probably do it more intentionally than I
just described but you get what I'm
saying create social media content and
then the key though right is
it does take effort to build it and how
are you going to Market it how you're
going to sell it how you get to set up
the funnels how you're going to set up
everything to to have it all work but if
you had a year to do it and it was a 37
000 course could you get a thousand true
fans thirty seven thousand dollars and
then imagine if it was 197 course
times a thousand true fans that's 197
000 at the beginning we ask the question
how are creators earning six seven and
even eight figures
I think we could see that man the a
thousand true fans model makes it
possible but now let's say you create an
online course for ninety seven dollars
and you're like saying Sean even a
thousand like it's hard enough getting a
thousand YouTube subscribers like to
actually get a thousand people who
really as Kevin Kelly in the article
describes it are really they buy
anything you sell like they're really
into your stuff
so let's say you make something for
ninety seven dollars you go it's a it's
a pipe dream okay let's really break it
down
so a 97 course
a thousand true fans is basically a six
figure a year income ninety seven
thousand dollars a year
caveat
if you're doing this
ad revenue and Affiliates is coming in
as well you know what I mean like you
you don't like stop getting ad Revenue
at this point like so point you you
could easily put if you do this you'd
push over six figures but let's go
really practical Year One
you get 250
uh true fans year one you hustle you're
putting in the work you're really
understanding not just social media
content but building a brand uh
curiosity marketing like different
things that you're understanding
and
in the first year though your 97 course
only does 250 sales
so that's 24 250 bucks
so if we make this super practical you
start thinking okay you're doing some
YouTube shorts they're not paying well
we all know that they're doing all right
on YouTube but you also upload those
vertical videos other places you upload
those on social media you really get
your kind of like Lincoln bio and you
you you get how to do social
um you know really clear then you can
uh get to that 250 sales in a year right
in a year and side note we also have
another resource available for a little
a limited time specifically about
Instagram as well as social media if you
didn't watch our free social media class
it's at um idea to income dot tips I
co-taught this with chalene Johnson and
so if you're interested in I know I know
you're in a deep dive class here but
like as I'm describing the Social Media
stuff
um this class is a much watch so you
could stream this free class idea to
income dot tips is where that's out and
so trying to go a little bit deeper on
just you know what we're talking about
um here in regards to
uh
uh let me get you the
yeah here we go so there's only a few
days left to check out the limited
replay of this class at idea to income
dot tips just sign up there if you want
to watch that let's bring this back up
and and then thinking about all of your
purposeful and intentional and
value-adding activities across social
media
are
and YouTube are 250 sales in a year
thanks for the Super Chat as well how to
vids I will definitely get to your
questions
um and if anybody else has any questions
especially super chat questions just let
me know
apparently we're going to be here all
day and I'm grateful for it uh year two
so let's go practical
oh Sean is Sean's a get rich quick guy
okay I mean whatever
this is year two I mean what starts you
know what I mean like we're talking no
like build your skills do the work
slow and steady wins let's make this
practical
and yes what is incredible is there's
something about it's like the harder I
work the luckier I get there is
something about oh man at month seven I
had a breakout video because it's true
we are each one viral video away
from changing our life in business we're
one ranked video away from changing our
life and business but let me ask you
this we call this the the Oprah dilemma
a lot of people know any Oprah fans that
if you were an author and your book
was shouted out by Oprah it was an
instant bestseller if you created some
kind of a program and you got to go on
Oprah's show and she sent people to your
website boom you you she could make your
business overnight but imagine the Oprah
dilemma you go on Oprah
you're thinking about making an online
course you're thinking about turning
what you knew into a product so she sits
you down and she's like hey Molly uh you
know I've heard you have created a
painting class I've heard you've created
a fine art class for others and I would
love you know how can people sign up and
then Molly goes oh well you know
you can go to mollysfineart.com but it's
it does say website under construction
but um could you but bookmark it but
bookmark the page
um or or you could go to Molly's fine
art.com and um
and like there's a picture of my idea
if it's not built yet
you missed your opportunity
now the good news is we're living in a
world where
opportunities are like buses there's
another one coming every day
but the prop this is why it's a mistake
to focus too much on YouTube and social
media before building your business
because what happens if on upload 45 on
YouTube
like Omar it gets 168
000 views but you've connected it
effectively
to
a profitable working website that can
sell your digital product
okay so year two though
you you your 97 course now does 500
units
okay and we're now being practical so so
even if wood if all
if you imagine yourself doing this
imagine creating an online course but
also picture yourself committing to the
journey not thinking that this is going
to happen in five minutes but where
could you be in five years
where could you be on the other side of
learning these skills so then let's look
at year three
if right now why maybe you have a day
job what would it do for you and your
family to bring in an extra twenty four
thousand two hundred fifty dollars this
year
Maybe by next year you're able to tell
your boss you could go part-time or you
can quit take that leap
then by year three you're doing 97 000
but then multiply that by the other
income streams so maybe you're doing 110
120 130 140.
you know there is a lot of studies that
have come out from Adobe and convertkit
about the crater economy that breaks
down this math that a lot of people
criticize oh this is fake it's not real
oh it's just a and you're like okay I
mean this is the math like it's just
this is why
uh I mean 168 million people joined the
Creator economy since
2020 there's the 50 million in the
crater and then it was millions are
earning six figure incomes
right and multiple millions are earning
high five you know an extra 10 an extra
20. 53 000 a year thousand true fans but
it doesn't even have to be a thousand
true fans right
um okay so what has been your aha moment
so far I do have one more framework for
you and if you've been getting value
smash like I am coming to your questions
how to vids and miss and I appreciate
your time today
um and we're at an hour and 50 13
minutes breaking every best practice on
YouTube but I mean welcome to
this class
what's been your aha moment so far let
me know I'm going to recap those and
again if if even in this class obviously
this is I'm not trying to say like I can
cover everything here we're covering
like the tip of the iceberg so
ultimately some of the skill sets to
learn right is like well what about
sales how do you actually sell it and
build the confidence to sell or sell
without being salesy sell without being
weird what about course creation how do
you actually structure it what's the
best way to create it adult learning
theory how do you organize it what about
email email marketing branding how do
you actually Stand Out Diffie
differentiate your business how do you
actually structure your business best
ways to structure online business
mistakes and all of that if you are
interested and this is only if you're
serious right and if you're if you're
interested in like learning from the
person who taught me all of this and
this is what I applied to my YouTube
course
and then I continue to go deeper and
I've been able to uh learn from uh
chalene Johnson that is why during the
last seven days or whatever we've been
talking about uh her program the
marketing impact Academy it does have
online courses in it but it is really
bigger than that it's more of like a a
lifelong Learning Resource because you
do get lifetime access because this is
always changing and because
at every level of the game there's
different stuff eventually might be like
how do I do Facebook ads like it's in
there you're like how do I do
um Pinterest ads you know how do I
eventually set up a store and chalene is
has built
seven seven or eight figure businesses
and built and sold businesses including
physical Goods hard Goods Fitness space
all this different stuff so it's
actually a much bigger Business program
but that's what I started to realize I
was like man I need to learn actually
how to build a real business the iceberg
underneath the YouTube channel so if
you're interested in that you can check
out the link in the um
show notes the description or Mia bonus
and am I a bonus is
we've promo it's been a couple years
since we promoted this but she opens the
door like once a year
um and so at Mia bonus.com
we always rally behind it because a we
believe in education and we believe in
skill sets uh and learning all this
stuff from somebody who's proven and can
teach you all of it but we also included
a couple extra things including
um our full-time YouTube Creator course
and YouTube shorts master class and our
video success secrets and our personal
branding master class which are just
extra bonuses at no extra charge because
we are an affiliate for chalene
Johnson's course yes I'm a knowledge
broker for her program because I can do
the YouTube thing you know built the
YouTube expertise wrote the book on
YouTube but if it also comes well what
about the iceberg what about all the
email marketing setting up the website
setting up the funnels well let me let
you know about the person who helped me
understand all of that and more and so
again definitely not right for uh
everybody but if you're serious and
you're like oh I get it I've been
thinking about doing this and I
understand the value of investing in
somebody that can help me go faster if
you value your time and don't just want
to look at random information but be a
part of something that can help you have
the shortest path to learning the skills
getting the answers getting the
information and doing the right things
in the right steps that's definitely
worth at least checking out an MIA
bonus.com is where that's at but I do
have one final framework for you
and I didn't realize uh how much I was
packing in today and we're gonna do a
few q a things here in a second but
um start with the end in mind one of my
favorite quotes Stephen Covey said it
perhaps first we always start with the
end of mine and we we work backwards
start with the end in mind and work
backwards I like doing it if we go okay
I get it
I do want to eventually launch a course
what does that actually mean for my
YouTube channel my branding you know or
start with the end in mind how do I do
this like what is it you know working
backwards but let's this specifically I
want to share with you the social media
sales funnel
and
what's the reason start with the end in
mind is so powerful is what a lot of
people do is they just start with social
media it's a mistake
because what you want to do is start
with the end in mind which actually
should be sales
and 99 of people do not do this right
the the
biggest thing that is so common and
honestly a lot more people this is we're
on a mission to double the crater
economy but not just inside of aspiring
creators but successful creators
and creators get obsessed though just
with the vanity metrics they focus all
on reach and I got to go viral and all
on Impressions and I got to get my count
as big as possible and I gotta it's they
think I want to be known by as many
people as possible they think that's the
key
they think that awareness that top level
is the key if I can just have them as
much awareness as possible as much when
start with the end of mind would
actually be to flip the whole thing what
are you building
what's the foundation where is this all
going
who's your ideal customer who's your
Target customer and who is and you might
be saying I've never even thought about
these things that might be why you're
struggling
because Stephen Covey that quote is from
Seven Habits of Highly Effective People
one of the most legendary personal
development books ever it's 20 30 40
years old or something start with the
end in mind and then work backwards so
knowing the steps of basically the
social media sales funnel is important
but but people are focusing on the wrong
things because remember this is also
what what would happen in awareness and
the Oprah dilemma
awareness just goes
and then they go to the next step and
there's nothing there
the website's down and do you know how
many people check out their bookmarks
and go back if if you
promote something and tell person tell a
person oh come back later you know what
I mean oh Oprah can you just let your
people know that like it'll be out in a
couple weeks can they set a reminder on
their phone like no if it's not ready
and working and and right
and the whole thing's not built and I
know that can feel overwhelming but I
also you're here for real truth
that's why it's getting your business
built properly so so awareness
and engagement is literally where almost
everybody's obsessed with but it is
important and fun
but a lot of times people procrastinate
are you getting leads let me ask you so
so this is where most people Focus right
okay can I at least get a vertical video
to get as many views can I see how many
comments I can get on a video can I see
how many likes I can get I'm trying to
get subscribers I'm just trying to get
awareness I'm trying to get some
engagement I'm just trying to get people
to watch good
okay let me ask you a question are you
capturing leads
is there a way for somebody to go off of
social media and to join you and it
doesn't even have to be an email list
although highly recommended it could be
text email Discord group Facebook group
somewhere else
have you noticed too especially why some
voices that are being censored and being
Shadow banned
and are looking at some of the actions
that big Tech makes build their own
newsletters and build their own
communities and diversify where they're
where people build their own websites
because at the end of the day if you're
dependent on a platform you don't have a
real business
so where are you generating leads and
then are you generating sales
and do you have something to sell your
income is correlated to the amount of
buy buttons you have on your website
well Sean I don't even have a website
well that could be why you're struggling
with income
well Sean I don't really have anything
to sell now to be clear you don't have
to actually create an online course
when I I started discovering inside of
the marketing impact Academy people
doing uh there's this cease shells
website they talk about it's like sea
ocean jewelry
Drop Shipping
or rather e-commerce importing from like
AliExpress
seashell jewelry setting up a Shopify
figuring out distribution and building a
multiple six-figure business
that you take something was so funny was
yesterday we did a review of a seashells
Channel Beach bumming and the video was
with Rob yesterday
five thousand Subs
and as I looked at it I thought this
channel
has limited up size potential
not to speak anything negative over the
channel but it's probably not going to
be 10 million subscribers and I don't
think it'll ever be a million and it may
never be a hundred thousand it's five
thousand right now
that doesn't mean it can't be a real
business but the key would be okay
if I actually had my Niche focused
YouTube channel but I was capturing
leads and I had a way to generate sales
physical products journals digital
products downloads templates remember
just other what are your leads and what
are your sales gonna be
let's recap online courses are one of
the best business models for creators
you can get started today as a knowledge
broker reporter or a results expert and
avoid the mistakes of focusing on
YouTube and social media before building
a solid online business I the spelling
errors are still are still present
reports report her
reporter or a results expert avoid the
mistakes of focusing on YouTube and
social media before building a solid
okay
for real-time professional here uh avoid
the mistake not plural of focusing on
YouTube and social media before building
that last point is not what I'm trying
to say avoid the mistake it is kind of
what I'm trying to say it's what we just
proved avoid the mistake of not building
your business first and getting the your
business in order before weight spending
all of your time on social media I was
about to say wasting and actually that's
a good word to say social media is not a
waste of time and YouTube is not a waste
of time but it can be if you don't have
the right things in place first
that would be the point to make
crashed and burned with that uh that
last slide but really grateful for it
and again if you want help I'm gonna do
some q a uh I highly recommend just
check out my Mia bonus.com if you have
any questions or anything too there's a
way to get in touch with me the team
um and
um if you haven't seen the interview
that chalene and I did that's on this
very channel the think media podcast
channel it's also on the audio version
of the podcast uh great conversation as
well that I highly recommend but I got
some q a if you have any uh questions
put four question marks before and after
your question smash like if you got
value today I'm going to start with the
Super Chat here how to vids hi Sean
thanks for the amazing information do
you recommend running an ad behind the
low ticket course such as the ones for
37 yeah that could be a good idea
um but when it comes to paid advertising
it that just becomes kind of a skill set
of of doing the math and doing is it
profitable or not
so
um ad costs have can go up and down at
different seasons and over the years
um is there more than just the 37 course
uh they do say in all e-commerce
uh what is the LTV lifetime value of a
customer what is the CAC what is the
cost of acquisition of a customer so if
it costs you fifty dollars to sell a 37
course you'd be losing 13 but if if it
costs you fifteen dollars per you know
so the ultimate thing would be yes but
that's the kind of nuance you want to
develop in your skill set
um to uh
uh
succeed with paid advertising Randy Sean
told me a year ago that the gospel is
free but what about discipleship courses
yeah I mean it's a really good point and
it's a good context because when we
think about something like religion like
the gospel
it is freely you've received freely give
and so of course we wouldn't preach the
gospel for any charge Paul literally
says that he's like I preached the
gospel without charge in fact I work to
pay my own bills even though I should be
given offerings so mostly in a
non-profit Church mindset we mostly
think of like offerings we think of
which is a model you can do for courses
there's a whole model of pay what you
want and what you'd be you'd be shocked
that people will
it's like free
and if some people can't afford it
they'll buy it for free
but some people will pay a thousand
dollars for something you know like and
so that is a model I think though the
flip side is there is a difference
between
the gospel
even discipleship I mean it is like
discipleship is
is should should be free but you also
have to you know pay meaning like can
you write a book how many books on
disciple I mean I I probably have 100
books on discipleships and I would I
paid 15 for them or whatever
all of that to summarize would be just
be thoughtful about what you're building
I think A discipleship course is is
great but what I wanted to get across
was
uh like leadership for example so like I
think there's some really good paid
products that are about like church
growth about how to preach better and
that kind of gets in the idea of B to B
versus B to C
um like if you're educating a Mastery
level skill set like of how to preach
better
um that's one that's kind of a little
bit different that's in a way it's B to
B not to say that church is a business
although it kind of operates like one
right is
versus B to C like the gospel is free
for everyone but if you want to be a
specialist like you want to become a
great Bible teacher I'm going to pay all
day long to become a great teacher you
know what I mean so the mindset even
when you're B2B or let's just say your
course is for professionals courses for
someone wanting to learn professional
skills and pastoring is a vocation so
does that make sense not saying you'd
have to make a leadership or a pastoring
or church growth course or something but
that whole thing is is kind of
interesting on itself but if you look at
Jeff Bethke saying that's ultimately A
discipleship course 40 bucks on how to
study the Bible workshops paid
conferences paid an online course I mean
people been charging
at churches they do
Financial Peace University from Dave
Ramsey 100 bucks
at churches you buy a 40 ticket to
listen to
Les parrot and his wife talk about how
to fight fair in marriage you go to
marriage classes they're paid classes
well now you're just taking that you're
putting it into a digital course
different things you can think about in
that Arena which platform is the best to
launch an online course we have a
resource called uh think media tools if
you're curious about
um
our favorite tools
and so uh
thinkmediatools.com and there's a lot of
different video editing resources on
here I do to this day I would encourage
you from two sides of the equation
um one
the best platform to host your course is
the one you actually use and get your
course launched with
so
and they're they all could be kind of
similar
so I am very familiar with thinkific
teachable kartra click funnels high
level
it goes on and on there's like weird
stuff like gumroad
by the way YouTube is going to be
integrating online courses because they
understand how big this is for YouTube
Here's why that is cool but I also
wouldn't use it is because YouTube
charges you 30 percent
on your channel memberships so if you
got to six figures thousand true fans
you got a hundred thousand dollars a
year YouTube would take thirty thousand
dollars
of the thing you're adding value at a
deeper level respect they can do what
they want kind of like the mafia I guess
you know they're like pay me they're
like oh I'm gonna break your fingers
um
so weird and uh so if they charge you
if you hosted on like kajabi though and
kajabi is what we use I mean if there
was one thing I recommend and and we've
thoroughly vetted a lot of them and the
reason I love kajabi is because it's
like all the things
and once you get into the things there's
like a lot of things so if you go to
think media tools we have uh kajabi and
let's see oh yeah it's you know all the
tools you need in one place and you
don't need to be tech savvy also here's
another reason why I like it there's
um I got to meet the new CEO of kajabi
when I was speaking at VidCon last year
and I was asking about like who's the
biggest the biggest doesn't mean the
best but I was like yeah is Click
funnels bigger than you guys are like it
was funny too he wasn't even being like
arrogant he was just like what are you
talking about like we are the leading
and so somebody could fact check me but
here's what I think about when I think
about software
how many developers do they have how are
they improving it am I investing
something that's going to grow that's
going to be competitive that's going to
continue to add new features that's
going to integrate AI That's going to
continue to be better because if you're
building your online business of course
you could change but it's kind of a
headache to change so I just want to
like One Stop Shop let me pick it out so
um you could check that out and uh we
could drop a link for you as well to uh
kajabi
um
but you could even do a free a free
trial and if you check this out I'm a
little bit distracted here but this
would be very valuable
um create online courses podcasts
memberships
profitable podcasts made easy
build Authority uh Apple Google Spotify
upload your podcast integrate it
they also have comparisons kajabi versus
Circle kajaba reverse click funnels
kajabi versus stickific and you could
compare and contrast
um
eventually you'll you'll make that
decision I don't know if I would it is
part of the equation but I think even
getting clear on
who is it you're going to reach and what
problem do you solve and what chalene
Johnson would call your lifer is is
super critical and then of course
budgeting things out and then kind of
identifying the services one of the most
valuable things I found inside of the
marketing impact Academy
was
um
uh
her in-depth breakdown of all of the
platforms so that's one of the things
that
she covers and one of the things I mean
whether it's Mia or not meaning this
offer that she has and you can see all
our stuff at Mia bonus.com or not
let me just suggest that personally
like you being here
man you should Outsource your learning
and Outsource your your uh knowledge to
other experts because there's just too
much that's also why she put she has
like 30 different teachers in there
because any one individual can't
possibly know all this stuff that's why
it's like give me paid by numbers you
know what I mean I actually am trying to
answer your question best and as you can
see we're pretty seasoned at this point
but I like open this up and I'm like
circle like what the back is circle
although I think Pat Flynn uses that and
so uh and my warning for you is just
don't get too into the weeds of any of
this stuff man it's like it's you know
like pick kajabi and roll with it you
know that would be that would be the
opportunity so
um
awesome
and uh Victoria just shared our link to
kajabi if you want to check that out
okay
build an online course or build an
audience first good question Walter
um
my answer is both
my answer is
most people take they they focus too
much on building an audience for too
long first
um and then finally though it really
does truly depend
so Walter I would ask like for example
would it be wise for you to perhaps
figure out how to be a knowledgeable
better answer and I'm I know she was
starting questions throughout Victoria
starting questions I mean learn how to
Market brand Niche down understand your
audience and be a knowledge broker first
then be a reporter second then build an
online course fully on your own a
results expert third
that would be a good sequence however
many people in our community you could
be one
are results experts
so
you're perhaps ready now therefore your
path and your approach would be a little
bit different an assessment and
self-awareness of where you what are
your skills
um you know
do you have a current audience or
whatever
um and what is also fascinating is if
you there are many people who have some
of the smallest audiences who make the
most money because they learn an
entirely another set of skills direct
response marketing paid advertising for
example
um is not relying on the slow and steady
growth of organic
it's actually learning a whole nother
set of skills and just going directly to
problem solving
I'm not recommending skillshare you to
me
however you can actually make a course
on udemy which is like a public online
course Marketplace
and have it get discovered on its own by
search like I discovered that chat GPT
course because I searched first so
I'm throwing a lot at you it's a lot to
think about
um but it depends is honestly the answer
to that question will Mia show you which
software apps that can help you set up
your online course for the best success
100 and this is uh not to stress you out
but if all Mia did for you was Hold Your
Hand which one of the coolest things
they have is an assessment
and again what he's talking about is the
Mia bonus thing where you can see more
on this but
you eventually need a CRM that's your
customer customer relationship
management that's like your email
marketing software is that can also be
inside of kajabi are you at some point
going to use some kind of a text message
thing like Community or something
which tools should you have and which
tools would you overspend on marketing
impact Academy is not cheap it is an
investment but when you're investing in
building an actual business it actually
is incredibly affordable compared to
what it would cost to go to a university
or college 50 Grand a year it's like a
fraction of that but also compared to
the startup costs of traditional
businesses but then also compared to the
pain of wasting time and money on
resources and tools you don't need so
100 is a really good question
um getting you know what it's called in
business today but especially in online
business is it's called a tech stack I
was doing coaching I went on one
coaching with David Bay from American
Business Heroes yesterday
or what day is it Tuesday it's a
Thursday this week
and we were talking about his Tech stack
and he was already getting into you know
eventually uh Patrick David he has a
tech stack for selling insurance
policies and so these days that think
media
this is not advice for starting but as
we have team members and contractors in
our Tech stack is money.com and
slack and kajabi
an active campaign
and you go well Sean I'll just use the
apps you're using that would be smart
you could just copy like those
however
there's probably not a conversation I
have with chalene Johnson where I'm not
like learning and being like Oh shoot
like that's not good anymore and like
email deliverability rates and and
compared to other platforms so there's
just a level of
um yeah it's very helpful to also be in
like a private if you have a group they
have a private group where you can learn
from other people that are doing this
and like iron sharpens iron like I'm
trying to do this particular feature and
someone goes oh yeah I had that problem
people there's like Infusionsoft if you
ever heard about that it's called
Infusionsoft a lot of people call it
confusion soft because it's so dang hard
to use so also finding something that's
gonna be easy for you and fast for you
and that's what I love about chalene
Johnson because she's shock's all about
being add and having trouble focusing so
everything that she communicates is done
in such a way to keep it simple as
friction free as possible just tell me
what to do just tell me the steps and
let me just do it so I don't get bogged
down and maybe that would be the summary
of a lot of this
invest if you can in the shortcut of
just painting by numbers with a program
like marketing impact Academy
but no matter what you do don't let
overthinking or analysis paralysis stop
you
because
uh
it's better to have an imperfect plan
executed like crazy this month
then waiting for the perfect plan
executed next year
because if you if we wait until tomorrow
we're going to be waiting the rest of
our lives
I think it was lemendy's Thicket that
said that
um
if we wait until we're ready we're going
to be waiting for the rest of our lives
quote Lemony Snicket
I just created a course for newbies I
already sold some copies hey
congratulations Allison how can I make
YouTube videos that lead to the course
without teaching the course information
um very good question I'm noting the
question to think about how because I
have so much to say probably too much to
say and we're at an hour 40 minutes
um
but uh Allison the I would definitely
create a freebie and I'm sure you've
heard of those and I would maybe just
make great videos let me give you like
one example
like you could do what we call Trend
surfing entirely different than teaching
anything in a way
you react to news related to your online
course you react to what's happening in
culture and then you're like and by the
way if you want to learn about this I
have a free thing and then people could
opt in for it and that leads to your
course so there's
probably 26 different actually literally
I'm trying to think about what we'd call
them we call them like um leads not
leads like emails but like
like video topics
almost like angles on it and that was
one of them and so there's probably 21
different ones we use but one of them
would be like
if you had a
uh a course on how to lose weight and
reset your metabolism you do a YouTube
video on a new article about
health obesity and what's happening in
America makes sense and you could have
like a shocking YouTube title because
it's like new data reveals like
Americans health is crashing and what we
need to do about it and you're like this
is crazy here's some thoughts by the way
if you didn't if if you didn't know I
have a seven day
um you know detox your body challenge
you could does that make sense so so
just doing Trend surfing and and
teaching yes but tapping into culture
and then you can give a call to action
to like your free thing that'd be one
way to do it and that that way of
thinking and I'm talking we was like 21.
Market impact Academy is like 2 000 uh
ways of of approaching that and that's
not to exaggerate that's to say those
type of
it's to oversimplify that's what online
marketing would be understanding
different angles and approaches and
human psychology and different ways to
position your content not just on
YouTube but what would be the best
practices to do that across platforms
chalene is an Instagram expert heavily
her and Brock blowing it up there but
she brings in guest experts I'm inside
of marketing impact Academy teaching on
YouTube she brings in guest experts on
podcasting and video podcasting because
same thing how could really any one
person be a true expert at every single
thing that's why she built basically a
university it's like marketing impact
University really with multiple
different teachers that cover just the
thing you need because it would also be
a mistake for us to try to be great at
all social media platforms just when
we're starting all right
that was still a long answer but I'm
really grateful if you're getting value
hit like I'll answer a couple more
questions at the hour and 42 minute Mark
take a sip of the coffee any aha moment
so far
um
what's uh what are you up to
keep yeah by the way there's some great
content I'm seeing from you all in the
comments y'all are sharing the different
things you're using
uh the coffee is cold now Victoria in
the private chat is yeah it's cold but
it's good my coffee changes flavor
when you have good single origin coffee
this was uh
from Costa Rica
the flavor profile actually changes
I don't love great coffee Aeropress Burr
grinder
um you know made it right before I came
up here didn't really drink it
because we got into the live stream when
it's hot it's not even the best flavor
there's different when it's kind of
almost like
too hot to drink you lose the flavor
when it's lukewarm warm delicious
lukewarm but even cold sounds weird but
it actually is like there's a whole
other dimension to the notes
kind of have the kind of a strawberry
there kind of a lime tartness
that sort of meets the
maybe melon it's delicious
um I always drink my coffee cold
my friend
We Are One
all right a couple uh land in the plane
uh and then and by the way in just all
full transparency two with you uh this
whole Mia bonus thing there's only a
couple more days left on it we talked
about it a few days ago in that free
class which you can also watch if you
want at idea to income.tips but it is it
is truly limited because
chalene does have kind of like an
onboarding process and then you kind of
get into everything and then as all the
materials roll out so if you're on the
fence check it out at Mia bonus.com you
want if you have more questions or
whatever definitely take action on that
even if you are able to open a second
window or something while you're
watching this and you have any questions
about what you see there let me know and
uh I would love to answer some of those
uh Victoria does anybody else taste just
coffee yeah probably if it's Keurig
yeah probably if it's
Folgers
yeah probably if it's I'm I it might be
clear enough that I'm a coffee snob like
maybe that's been revealed to you
already
um Victoria what kind of coffee do you
drink
Victoria's part of our uh think team
here and uh
I will tell you this though I'm I try to
be kind and empathetic in social
situations but when I'm over at like
someone's house or whatever and they
like offer me coffee
I kind of am like
like what is it like how will it be made
and I could have got no sleep my kids
kept me up all night long like I feel
awful I really want coffee and they're
like yeah I made some coffee do you want
a cup and I'll be like oh yeah yeah what
is it
oh it's uh
it's a keurig's Starbucks Pike Place
blend no thanks I'd rather die and I
walk out into the street and hope to end
my that was morbid okay so anyways we uh
we're creating some uh
yeah French Press is fire I agree with
that
uh yes the taste is much better you
roast your own beans
this is Brazilian coffee yes come on
let's go we got some people
um
I drink whatever organic coffee organic
is kind of important but that's
that distinction is not one of the key
distinctions here let me um break down
uh I'll post the affiliate links in the
description
of my favorite coffee places
um
pick the time codes if you want to skip
past this and you're watching this on
the replay
because sorry to waste your time here
but now this is where we're going and
this has been my decision okay so you've
got uh Onyx Coffee lab
by the way I was joking about Affiliates
but I wonder if they have an affiliate
program
they don't maybe they do Victoria can
you see if they do I'm just curious and
then we could link it up this place is
amazing I'm typically my two favorite
regions are going to be Ethiopia and
Colombia so
um Cola I gotta close this colon I'll
give you three Columbia so
um again you got a little fluoro floral
honey chocolate milk always whole whole
beans that'd be another thing if if
someone's like if I'm not hearing the
beans grind before they make the coffee
like no thank you so it's not bad you
know 21 for 10 ounces it's kind of small
but 21 so let's see onyxcoffeelab.com
um another good one here in Vegas would
be Vesta Coffee Roasters they ship as
well so Vesta is absolute fire
um I think I'm sipping on this this
Ethiopia is great this Kion Mountain uh
it's really good and uh I it's kind of
shocking how many bags of coffee I have
um downstairs right now
my one of my favorites is black and
white coffee roasters whenever I go to
town I look for like hipster spots
and then I will follow up online ooh
black labels out so yeah
see I have too much coffee downstairs
right now but I'm about to make some
online purchases after this
um let's see how much these are
75 dollars for the Black Label
competition competition uh set here
and only 100 grams of each for 75
dollars
Victoria is this what you're drinking so
black and white is is really good
um and
the future pretty good I bought four
bags of that and was given them out to
Kyle and Omar and Mel I think I gave one
to Brock Johnson when he was on the
podcast
um and
uh and and we lost everybody watching
okay
um
poop coffees have I ever tried the poop
coffee I haven't I've heard of it but I
absolutely would I wouldn't even
hesitate and um that's that would be
great
I'm down what was it that I was there
was something I was eating drinking
recently that my wife was like you are
disgusting and I'm never kissing you
again and I was like
that sucks
final questions we're going to end
before two hours what funnel do you
recommend to get started uh
no time and we have time but too deep of
a question but uh
stick with us subscribe if you're not
subscribed definitely check out Mia
bonus that's you learn all that stuff
there how do you improve your value
proposition to your channel subscribers
it's a good question I think you should
study them depending on who's there ask
them questions
but a lot of people underestimate the
time they should take getting to know or
clarifying who exactly it is that they
want to reach and then once you like
kind of a simple way to put it
is sort of like uh Love Languages by
Gary Chapman the book
and the movement
you know
how do you add more value to your spouse
if you don't understand what would add
value to your spouse
so
and if you do understand so I could go
pitch my wife and be like
hey babe uh do you want to order pho
Pho right and
uh bring it home to the house and watch
Starcraft 2.
gameplay videos
all afternoon
and then uh
bing bong bing bong
hint
everything up the channel just so you
can see my favorite YouTube channel
right now this is not it uh winter
Starcraft
Mel was shocked it'll show you my watch
time on this channel
uh you can see these red red lines of
like how much of these episodes I'm
watching
that's 46 minutes
this was 49 minutes this is someone else
playing Starcraft 2 which is a 13 year
old game here's the point this is this
is a I hope it makes a good point uh how
do you add a better value proposition so
if I go honey
want to uh get what she hates watch
Starcraft 2 which she thinks is stupid
and then bing bong bing bong which does
not happen if I make mistake number one
and number two
um then my value proposition wasn't very
good for her right but if I was like hey
babe wanna go antique shopping go
someplace cool with really delicious
burgers and fries and then I'll give you
a back rub no expectations
wow it's a better value proposition I
was able to get her attention I was able
to close the sale
because even perhaps the no expectations
but the better sequencing LED
to better results you put the per you
put the viewer first you put the person
first you put your spouse first and you
you seek to understand and discover and
be aware of the nuances might we argue
that of course in a relationship that
should be give and take let's do what
you want to do let's do what you want to
do but I would also argue that it would
be a selfish
you can be selfish sometimes list of
daily activities
if I was to suggest my activities for
the day
um and uh
here we are
is that helpful
um
yes you gotta talk their language and
see what they
want
um
yes amazing very good okay uh
where would you recommend starting to
learn about how to set up and run an
email list I mean Chris just start
studying it or take the fast track and
go to Mia bonus.com and follow the next
steps I mean join marketing impact
Academy that is what I learned where I
learned even in some it goes very deep
even in terms of like setting it up what
to say what to write what to do in in
automated email sequences and and this
stuff Chris is also a lifelong learning
um and that's why I think I mentioned a
little bit earlier that like even in
when I interview or connect with
somebody we we're like continuously
talking about it because it's just the
world's always changing the Market's
shifting technology is changing so being
committed to a program like that that
does have lifetime access is an
investment in a resource that becomes
like your marketing branding and online
business assistant for the rest of your
life like for the years of building it
up so
um if you can afford it and you're
committed I would recommend going that
direction otherwise just take the
subject matter and just study it deeply
and practice uh I I know business I
would like to broker how do I approach
them
as far as I know they don't have
Affiliates shoot them an email shoot
them an email shoot him a tweet stir up
a conversation see what's kind of
happening you'd be surprised uh what the
doors that could open
uh how do you estimate that you have a
thousand true fans based on your YouTube
Studio people always see your videos
recent viewers I think where this really
starts is you need to create a way to
uh build the text message list build an
email list build a Discord group build a
Facebook page Facebook group and it's
people that care to go to that deeper
level build a channel memberships
the air quotes I don't love Channel
memberships I respect it though we just
did an interview with Mary's Nest she's
going all in on channel memberships why
because of simplicity
and it's just her and her husband she
doesn't really want to grow a team she's
65 and she's okay with YouTube taking 30
I go I'm going to work a little bit
harder and figure out how to not use
Channel memberships so that I can save
the 30 but it would be that person that
wants to go to that deeper level and I
would recommend check out Kevin Kelly's
article on Thousand true fans
um all right we're at an hour and 54
minutes and so I'm super grateful that
you uh were hanging out today if you
have any more aha moments drop them
in the comments
um and if you uh made it this far and
you haven't checked out Mia bonus.com
just as a heads up there is uh limited
time remaining
um this will be like a wait list page or
something if you're watching the replay
when this is all over we have 3288
dollars of extra resources that we've
included in this if you've been a part
of our stuff for any um length of time
uh inside of marketing impact Academy
it's Brandon Business foundations
freemium's email marketing product
creation social media sales and
testimonials video and live streaming
content creation your online business
blueprint very deep and you can see all
those details but at Mia bonus.com we've
included our full-time YouTube Creator
course our YouTube shorts Master Class
our video success Secrets event which is
three days including an entire business
day chalene Johnson spoke there
um as well I our personal branding
master class which is just additional
bonuses that we're offering because of
course a we fully believe in the program
it is a program that changed my life
inside of just these live recordings
like there were sessions that were so
impactful I mean there's Lewis Howes and
Pat Flynn and Brandon burchard and Amy
Porterfield a lot of people in here but
like I just remember uh learning in some
of those like chalene on a whiteboard
talking about email marketing for 45
minutes and us going from like ten
thousand dollars a month to twenty
thousand dollars a month it's wild as
things grow and scale about thinking
about we say small tweaks lead to Giant
Peaks so anyways you can see all the
details about this at Mia
bonus.com uh just for a limited time
that is available it's not any kind of
false scarcity or anything weird it's
just truly uh how she runs her program
and while she's doing this promotion we
are
um you know offering these bonuses extra
bonuses as well and Link in the
description as well
aha Trend surfing yeah Susan appreciate
it that's a good one
um Mia is the race track route for sure
for sure your driver Mike appreciate you
thanks for being here always good to see
you really appreciate you how to vids
I'm really grateful for this super chat
um and you can see Victoria whether
you're on Facebook or on YouTube you can
see Mia bonus.com
um and
she has posted a link there if you want
to click that or just type the URL into
your browser my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel this is the
think media podcast and if you want to
check out the video I did with chalene
Johnson uh that you can just watch on
here as well you can click or tap the
screen to check that out I believe
you'll find that valuable and I will see
you